>>Trey Joyner: At Normal
Park, we focus largely
on creating an atmosphere
for the students
to give them an outlet,
give them an opportunity
to exhibit the work that they've
been doing, the learning.
>>Emily Pittman: Exhibits are
the way that we allow students
to take ownership
over their learning.
>>Jamie Tipton: So, each
year, the students will put
on four different exhibits,
and they work with all four
of their teachers on that
team to have a cohesive theme.
In each one of the
exhibits, there is a piece
from the math class, the reading
class, the language arts,
social studies, and science.
They all work together.
In addition to that, we
work with related arts teams
to add visual arts, art pieces,
Spanish pieces, German pieces,
and the library will even write
text and books with the kids.
Each quarter, we sit down as a
team and we assess what needs
to be learned, and from
that, we create the big ideas
or essential questions, and
so, for the entire quarter,
students are presented
at the very beginning
with the essential questions.
They learn in art class ways
to incorporate art pieces
to showcase one of the
essential questions.
In writing, they will expand and
write persuasive pieces or poems
to express that, and at
the end of the eight weeks,
we put the exhibit on.
The exhibit is a way to
show every understanding
that the kids have.
>>Jill Levine: Teachers
look at the big ideas
and then the knowledge and
skills, what the students have
to know and be able to do.
Then they look at, how are
we going to assess that?
For us at a museum
magnet school,
those assessments
are our exhibits.
They are often the labels
that go with the exhibits.
>>Jamie Tipton: Students
create exhibit labels
for every single piece
that's on exhibit
to let the audience know what
this is and why it's important.
Inside the exhibit label,
you should see the academic
vocabulary, a connection
to the content or the piece,
and then a personal connection.
>>Carrie Willmore: When I'm
asking them to write a label,
I want to make sure
that they remember all
of the academic language that we
talked about, all of the things
that we studied, so that they
can really show their best
understanding of that
essential question.
>>Jill Levine: After
the exhibits go up,
we have a faculty meeting in
which teachers walk through all
of the exhibits and they look
for evidence of understanding,
and then we'll share those
out at the faculty meeting.
That really helps to get
everybody on the faculty
on the same page in terms of
our expectations for exhibits
and what are true
understandings.
Every nine weeks, we have this
big celebration of learning,
and the halls will be filled
with parents and children
who are all here to
celebrate what their children
have accomplished.
For me as a principal, I
like to go up to students
and have them explain an exhibit
to me so that I understand,
did they get the big idea?
You know, did they
just do a project,
or did they really understand
what they did, why they did it,
and what it means in terms
of the bigger picture?
I think have lots of
schools have ballgames
and plays and concerts.
This is a way to
celebrate what goes
on in the classroom
day in, day out.